Bonjour à tous !
Aujourd'hui, je voudrais vous parler d'une stratégie infaillible pour gagner au poker.
Alors quand même, ne vous excitez pas trop vite,
vous allez voir que cette méthode est assez difficile à utiliser
et n'espérez pas avec devenir riche en écumant les tables de Las Vegas
ou les sites de poker en ligne.
Mais je ne vous raconte pas des blagues, vous allez voir qu'il existe réellement
une méthode imbattable pour gagner au poker.
♪ [Générique] ♪
Alors, avant de vous parler de poker, je voudrais d'abord vous parler de quelques autres jeux.
Prenez le champion du monde d'échecs.
À l'heure actuelle, c'est un petit génie norvégien qui a vingt cinq ans et qui s'appelle Magnus Carlsen.
Il est très fort aux échecs. Il est même très, très fort.
Pourtant, il n'est pas imbattable.
C'est à dire que, des fois, un autre champion arrive à le battre.
De plus, on sait que s'il jouait contre un ordinateur, vraisemblablement, il perdrait.
En effet, cela fait plusieurs années que l'on sait pertinemment que les ordinateurs
sont plus forts que les humain aux échecs,
et d'ailleurs, vous remarquerez qu'on n'organise plus de compétitions de ce genre là.
Pourtant, même les meilleurs programmes informatiques ne sont pas imbattables.
C'est à dire qu'on peut très bien imaginer qu'on arrivera un jour à mettre au point un programme qui sera encore plus fort.
Aujourd'hui, ce dont je voudrais vous parler, c'est une situation un peu différente :
c'est celle de jeux pour lesquels il existe un stratégie qui est mathématiquement imbattable.
C'est le cas d'un certain nombre de petits jeux simples,
et vous allez voir que depuis quelques mois c'est aussi le cas du poker.
Quand, pour un jeu, des joueurs ou des mathématiciens arrivent à trouver une stratégie
qui est mathématiquement imbattable,
on dit que le jeu est "résolu".
Alors il existe un exemple assez connu de jeu qui est parfaitement résolu : c'est ce qu'on apelle le jeu des bâtonnets.
Peut-être connaissez vous ce jeu si vous suivez l'émission Fort Boyard,
ou alors vous pouvez aller voir la vidéo de Micmaths qui traite du sujet.
Je vais vous faire une petite démonstration de ce que c'est que le jeu des bâtonnets.
Alors en fait ça se joue avec vingt bâtonnets (moi j'utiliserai des crayons de couleur)
Le principe du jeu est le suivant : ça se joue à deux,
chaque joueur a son tour prend soit un, deux ou trois bâtonnet(s).
Et les joueurs jouent à tour de rôle,
et celui qui prend le dernier bâtonnet est le perdant.
Faisons un petit exemple, alors voilà, imaginons, j'ai vingt bâtonnets,
et hop, le premier joueur prend, disons, deux bâtonnets, le deuxième en prend trois...
Le suivant, il en prend trois, celui d'après n'en prend qu'un...
Lui trois, lui deux, et puis lui... deux, et puis lui, trois.
Et là, vous voyez qu'il n'en reste plus qu'un. Je suis donc obligé de le prendre, et donc j'ai perdu.
Eh bien, ce jeu des bâtonnets, il est résolu.
C'est à dire qu'on connaît une stratégie permettant de gagner à coup sûr.
Cette stratégie, elle est relativement simple, je vous la donne :
si vous êtes le premier joueur,
vous commencez par prendre trois bâtons
et, ensuite, chaque fois que c'est votre tour,
si votre adversaire a pris N bâtons, vous en prenez quatre moins  N.
Donc s'il en a pris un, vous en prenez trois, s'il en a pris deux,
vous en prenez deux aussi, et s'il en a pris trois vous en prenez un.
Et vous pouvez vous convaincre que cette stratégie va permettre de gagner à tous les coups.
Puisqu'il existe une stratégie imbattable pour gagner au jeu des bâtonnets, on dit que le jeu est résolu.
Évidemment, vous voyez que ça ne marche que si vous êtes le premier joueur.
Si vous êtes le deuxième joueur et que votre adversaire applique la stratégie que je viens de vous donner,
vous ne pourrez jamais gagner.
Pour certains jeux, la situation est un peu différente :
dans les jeux où il n'y a pas forcément de gagnant, où il peut y avoir match nul.
C'est par exemple le cas du morpion.
Alors le morpion lui aussi est résolu, dans le sens où l'on connaît des stratégies qui permettent
de ne jamais perdre, c'est à dire de faire à coup sûr
soit un match nul, soit une victoire.
Évidemment, si les deux joueurs connaissent la stratégie,
ça devient vite assez chiant puisque ça veut dire que la partie donnera tout le temps un match nul.
Alors il existe un certain nombre de jeux un petit peu plus subtils que le morpion qui ont déjà été résolus,
c'est le cas notamment du jeu de dames.
C'est aussi le cas du Puissance 4, il existe une stratégie si vous êtes le premier joueur
qui permet, à coup sûr, de gagner au Puissance 4.
Les échecs, eux, n'ont pas encore été résolus.
C'est d'ailleurs assez peu probable qu'ils le soient :
c'est à dire qu'il existe peut-être une stratégie imbattable, mais à ce jour elle n'a pas été découverte.
Alors, pour certains jeux, la stratégie infaillible
peut prendre une forme aléatoire. Je vais prendre l'exemple du jeu "pierre, feuille, ciseaux".
Il existe une stratégie imbattable pour ce jeu :
C'est de jouer soit pierre, soit feuille, soit ciseau,
avec, exactement et parfaitement, une probabilité d'un tiers pour chaque.
Donc : vous jouez, et, à chaque fois que c'est votre tour, vous choisissez absolument au hasard
parmi les trois possibilités.
Et si vous faites ça, vous êtes sûr, sur le long terme, de ne jamais perdre.
Alors évidemment, à court terme, sur un coup, vous pouvez très bien perdre.
Cependant, à long terme, au moment où le facteur "chance" disparaît,
vous êtes sûr de ne pas perdre en utilisant cette stratégie là.
Venons-en maintenant au poker.
la variante du poker dont on va parler aujourd'hui,
c'est le Heads up Limit Hold'em.
Donc, j'imagine que vous conaissez le Hold'em : c'est la variante moderne du poker,
c'est celle où chaque joueur ne possède que deux cartes qu'il garde cachées,
et où on a jusqu'à  cinq cartes en commun pour tous les joueurs.
Alors, plaçons nous dans la situation qu'on appelle "Heads Up", c'est à dire quand on n'a que deux joueurs, un contre un.
Et la variante plus précise qu'on considère, c'est la variante qu'on appelle Limit :
C'est à dire que c'est une situation où le montant de la relance est fixé.
Quand c'est votre tour de jouer, vous n'avez que trois choses possibles à faire :
suivre, vous coucher ou bien relancer d'une quantité fixe.
Alors on fixe une quantité (par exemple, deux jetons) et la relance sera toujours de deux jetons.
Comme pour les échecs, des gens ont commencé à mettre au point des programmes informatiques
Qui soient capables de jouer au poker dans cette variante là.
Notamment, un groupe de recherche de l'université d'Edmunton, au Canada,
qui a publié en 2007 un programme
pour la première fois capable de battre un joueur professionnel de poker.
C'est un programme qui s'appelle Polaris.
Ce programme était très, très fort : il battait des pros,
mais il n'était pas mathématiquement imbattable.
Il était juste très fort, comme les programmes qui jouent aux échecs aujourd'hui.
Et, début 2015, cette même équipe a poussé le bouchon beaucoup plus loin,
puisqu'ils ont cette fois résolu le jeu de poker dans cette variante, Heads Up Limit.
Ils ont ainsi publié un nouveau programme, Cepheus
et qui, lui, est mathématiquement imbattable.
Évidemment, quand on dit qu'un programme de poker est mathématiquement imbattable,
C'est comme pour le pierre-feuille-ciseau, ça doit s'entendre sur le long terme :
si vous jouez seulement un tour avec lui et que vous avez une paire d'As,
il y a de bonnes chances que vous le battiez,
mais, sur le long terme, quand le facteur "chance" s'annule, vous ne pourrez jamais le battre,
quelle que soit la stratégie que vous allez jouer.
**jingle funky**
Je suis sûr que vous avez envie d'en savoir un peu plus sur cette fameuse stratégie mise au point par Cepheus.
Heureusement pour l'intérêt du poker,
Elle ne tient pas du tout en deux lignes comme dans le cas du jeu des bâtonnets.
En fait, elle est même si complexe,
que rien que pour stocker la stratégie, il faut un disque dur de 11 To.
Ce qui est intéressant, ce que pour mettre au point cette stratégie,
les concepteurs du programme l'ont fait jouer contre lui-même un (très) grand nombre de fois.
Et, pendant deux mois, Cepheus a joué contre lui-même
en faisant environ six milliard de parties par seconde.
Six milliards de parties par seconde pendant deux mois !
C'est à dire que, probablement qu'à chaque seconde,
Cepheus a joué plus de parties de poker que toute l'humanité de puis l'invention du poker.
Même si la stratégie suivie par Cepheus n'est probablement pas applicable pour des humains,
c'est quand même intéressant pour en apprendre sur la manière de jouer au poker.
Alors, déjà, vous pouvez aller sur le site de l'Université d'Edmunton,
et vous pouvez jouer contre Cepheus pour voir comment il se comporte.
Vous pouvez également lui soumettre des situations :
c'est à dire que vous lui dites quelles sont vos cartes, ce qui est sorti, comment les gens ont enchéri,
et Cepheus vous dira quelle est la stratégie optimale à suivre dans ce genre de situation.
Une autre chose qui est utile, c'est de voir comment Cepheus joue en tout début de tour,
c'est à dire au moment où on a juste deux cartes et où rien n'est sorti.
et on peut voir que Cepheus a tendance à suivre de stratégies qui sont relativement agressives.
Par exemple, quand il est donneur, Cepheus ne suit jamais.
Soit, il se couche quand il a vraiment un jeu pourri, soit il relance.
Et ce qui est marrant, c'est qu'il relance avec un jeu qu'on aurait envie de juger vraiment pourri,
pour, par exemple, un quatre et un six qui ne sont même pas de la même couleur.
Pour les puristes, évidemment, la version du poker de laquelle on parle aujourd'hui
est tout de même relativement restreinte : elle se joue à deux joueurs,
et, je vous l'ai dit, il s'agit de la version Limit,
c'est à dire une version où le montant de la relance est fixe.
Ce qui empêche toutes la stratégies telles que "je relance comme un malade", "je fais tapis", etc.
Donc il y a quand même toute une partie de la psychologie du poker qui est absente de cette version là.
Il n'empêche que le groupe de l'université d'Edmunton continue de travailler sur ces questions là.
Peut-être un jour sortiront-ils un programme
qui sera capable de battre des humains professionnels au No Limit...
Et, peut être un jour, résoudre le poker No Limit.
Mais, ça, il va falloir attendre pour le savoir.
Merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo, j'espère qu'elle vous a plu et qu'elle vous aura donné envie de vous intéresser
un peu à toutes ces question mathématiques de stratégies dans les jeux.
N'hésitez pas à partager la vidéo, c'est comme d'habitude le seul moyen qu'on n'a de faire connaître la chaîne.
Vous pouvez me retrouver sur Facebook, sur Twitter,
vous pouvez aussi me soutenir sur Tipeee, merci à tous les Tipeurs qui me soutiennent.
Et vous pouvez me retrouver sur mon blog, scienceetonnante.wordpress.com
Merci, et à bientôt !